[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print podcast on ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we take
your questions about your life and your
money this hour is devoted to the
timeshare industry
my contention is time shares suck you
should never buy one it's a complete
rip-off if you sell them you're ripping
people off and you should be ashamed of
yourselves most of you that run the
businesses know that you're scummy and
most of you that make billions of
dollars off of the american public
screwing them ought to really be ashamed
of yourself hope i wasn't unclear to
kick it off george that's a that's a
good contention i'm going to go with
your thesis on that one that it is true
it is ding ding ding so georgia hosts
the fine print and the fine print
podcast is all about money traps like
we're talking about today timeshares is
a great example of these people are
falling for this stuff across the board
and you know this from car leases to
student loan crisis and timeshares is
just one of these behemoths in the
industry that have been around forever
and so i'm excited to go after this with
you today yeah and we're gonna have to
devote a fine print podcast episode 100
eventually there's so much to do not on
the list yet but
beware it's coming it sucks so bad i
don't even know where to start that's
the problem it might take more than one
episode it's a series it's a series we
could just do a whole series of the
double fine print oh my goodness yeah so
uh we had the i
i had read a piece of research
advertised by the timeshare industry
that they had a 97
customer satisfaction to which i called
bs wow because anybody was walking
around since know that 97 percent of
people do not love their time shares
that's absolute horse crap
and so of course it's put out by the
industry which they kind of lie for a
living
sense you got to look at who's actually
yeah we're talking about diamond and
marriott and windham and westgate and
these companies are just laughably
horrible
and then
uh then there was a p a piece of
research done by the university of
central florida which said 97 of people
hate their timeshare which is that one i
kind of believed but then i got to
thinking i wonder what is real
and so i thought let's just do
not me doing it because my research
would be biased 100 percent i start with
a hypothesis of you people are crooks
okay but i didn't start that i just
called the i got the ramsey research
team which are very
nerdy
highbrow
very concerned about truth
and ethics not dave's exaggerations and
drama okay so they don't let me play in
their space much right but i can give
them direction to do a repeat of
research and i said hey
reach out to people that are inside the
ramsey tribe people that know ramsay
and people who have never heard of
ramsey and let's do some research and do
a good survey from the public
on what they really think of their time
shares
and so
not surprising to anyone
97 dislike or 97 like we're both wrong
oh okay where did we land it's it's it's
still horrible
but uh buyer's remorse here it is
this is detailed in-depth research large
sample size took several weeks to pull
it together
we actually spent some money on this
which is bothersome in a way but yeah
but it's but we did
57
of time share owners say that if they
could go back
they would not buy a timeshare again
that's six out of ten
so let me translate that for you if 57
of the ford truck buyers said they would
never buy a ford truck again
six out of ten of them that kind of
would say ford trucks suck yeah by the
way the research is actually quite the
opposite for ford trucks
uh just as an example not an
advertisement for four trucks by the way
the research is quite the officer for
chevy truck chevy truck people love
their chevy truck they'll go back again
and again and again ford people love
their ford trucks they'll go back again
and again and again and again and these
statistics just go on oh yeah and
we're talking about here with how many
people are happy about this like you're
saying six out of 10 people saying i
would not do this again makes me go i'm
going to do my research because
apparently there's a lot of unhappy
people there and if you look at the next
stat here 51 percent say that i don't
use my team my timeshare as much as i
thought i would so half of the people
aren't even using the thing that they
overpaid for
there we go
check
one in three time share owners agree
that time shares are not easy to use if
you currently own a time share
one-third of them say they're hard to
use
just like i have an app on my phone that
is hard to use do you know what i do
with it delete there you go bad purchase
a little shaky thing bad download right
yeah that thing right oh my goodness
gone that's bad just like that these
stats just go on and on and on 44 of
former owners say they were satisfied
with their timeshare experience
satisfied that's not that's not saying
they loved it just they were satisfied
man a lot of regret here um that's the
theme i'm getting regret
here's the one you gotta love though
only 48 of a time share owners say they
these are current timeshare owners not
somebody that just didn't buy walked out
of the meeting because it was high
pressure and scummy and all that but 48
of time share owners say they have a
great deal of trust
in the company who holds their timeshare
wow almost half of them trust their
timeshare company that's good that's
better than i would have thought
honestly the industry is that's like
saying i mean you know like they're in
the same categories like payday lenders
right
you know and payday lenders we pretty
much all know are scum they rip people
off charge 800 interest and so i mean i
don't think you could get 48 of them to
say they have a great deal of trust in
their payday lender no so that's pretty
good for the time sure guys and here's
the thing when you're looking at people
who own time shares you're probably
going to justify the decision a little
bit in your head even as you're taking
the survey you're gonna go well you know
it wasn't that bad of a deal because
you're trying to emotionally you know
cope with the fact that you made a dumb
decision so i think a lot of these
people are probably answering even with
a little more positivity than they
should be it does change when you go to
ramsey tribe though
one percent
yes one percent
of ramsey timeshare owners say they have
a great deal of trust in the ramsey in
the timeshare industry so that could be
my fault
yeah
if i get on here pretty regularly and
yeah this is these people are scum then
people believe it and they should
believe it because that way they won't
go in the tiger cage
because you know the tiger cages in case
you're new to this story
you're walking along the sidewalk and
the uh director of the zoo runs up and
says i will give you a free one-year
pass to the zoo all you have to do is go
into the tiger cage and pet the tiger
for an hour however remember that the
tiger has not been fed in three weeks
at three weeks and it's um
likely greedy
let's say yep and so um if you can get
out alive then you get your one year
pass to the zoo well that's like saying
you get a free vacation you can stay in
our place for free but you have to spend
two hours in the tiger cage pi penta
petting the very hungry greedy
no thank you no thank you and try to get
out alive i've seen tiger kings i know
how this ends
not playing that every episode you saw
every episode yeah binge watching me too
i lost my common sense card i've not
returned it since i watched every
episode
i blame covet that's what it is i think
kobe caused our minds to be warped a lot
of bad decisions who else so why
otherwise would we have watched tiger
game we're lacking in judgment george
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is the host of our
ramsey network
podcast the fine print
just launched a couple of weeks ago and
launched out at number one in the
business section super positive
dropping this week how to bulletproof
your money for the next pandemic that
was released today uh earlier uh how
turbo tax is screwing you and the true
cost of credit cards this is a whole
series of eight different our 10
episodes rather and we may be adding
another one to the
episode list when it comes to timeshares
which is what we're talking about today
george is with me to do that we were
noticing our research team when they did
the surveys also noted that
timeshares are an 11 billion dollar
industry
making it larger than major league
baseball
which is 9 billion in revenue
larger than the entire music industry
which is 8 billion
in revenue
and yet
50 to 60
of their customers are
at a minimum depending on which of the
statistics we read
and how we extrapolate them are uh
say we shall we say dissatisfied if you
are a timeshare customer currently and
you want to tell us your story good or
bad
we're exposing both today i'm willing to
hear your good story
um although i think they're kind of rare
but if you want to come in and uh
talk about the good things about your
time share that's cool god did that last
time i did one of these hours uh and
regardless of which company it is jump
in we want to hear the company we want
to hear what happened what's your time
share experience the phone number's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five luanne is in little rock
arkansas hi luanne tell us your time's
your story
hey dave hey george good to talk with
you
i'm um almost embarrassed to say it but
my husband and i it was back about 2013
11 to 13 there
we were up in branson and we had taken a
vacation mini vacation to uh for my
birthday and we ran out of money
and
they were advertising as we walked along
the sidewalk
uh
for a hundred dollars
they'll give you a hundred dollars if
you'll go for this 90-minute visit at
the west gate west gate up there
westgate for nine minutes or 90 minutes
90. okay nine nine zero
yeah
all right yeah
and
um
you know i was like oh we're not going
to buy one we're not doing we'll just go
get the money and work outside or
whatever you know yeah
exactly
and granted it's only four hours for us
to drive but gas was very low
and this was way before you dave okay
way before you know okay right
i feel better
way before
so
we went and did the 90 minutes end up
being about five hours and
yeah they roped us in because they start
pulling heart strings
and talking about the grandkids and you
know what you can do as a family and and
you know you don't want to say no to
this this is a good deal well
we said yes
and
it was about um
the reason they gave us that we could
get it but this really cheap price was
because
it was uh repo
basically
so
yeah they had a so you can repossess air
yeah right because there's no actual
asset
no no well and see that was one of the
likes too they told us that if we ever
wanted to sell and get out of it we
could resell it for a hundred thousand
wow easy yeah yeah not so
right not a hundred thousand seconds
yeah
our question was after we were stupid
and we ended up going about three or
four times to
the one in orlando because
once you go to one through them
you're stuck there
you cannot go to another one in their
system
and
you have to
we didn't have a certain week
but it was any week we wanted to go to
say park city utah or
go back to branson we couldn't go
because everybody was locked into just
that one
so
yeah so you know orlando's not cheap
and so we ended up saving up what we
could and we went to the timeshare well
every time we showed up there was
something wrong
with the timeshare they uh the air
conditioner wouldn't work
um they were you know overcrowded in
this section you couldn't pick the
section you wanted to be in and and so
they had to put you in this section with
the partiers and and basically the ones
that are
stupid out there too that are touring it
while you're there
and uh you just want to yell at them
please don't do it don't do it yeah it's
a trap it's trap you know so here we are
spending the
walking along with a client you're
trying to sell them this and luanne runs
up to them and drops down on her knees
and go don't do it
that would have been a great that would
have been a great visual that would have
been awesome i would do it now
what's the end of the story how did are
you still in it or did you get out oh no
no no no we uh quit paying for it for
two years
and in the meantime we had uh filed
bankruptcy
okay and we quit paying for it for two
years and uh
you know my husband
and i both i was like so what i worry
about things like that i'm like but we
we're gonna be in trouble we're gonna be
in trouble he said let's just see so
he's very analytical and an i.t guy so
we didn't pay for it for two years and
we didn't get any kind of notice we just
kept getting the same amount you know
all the time well after that two years
was up we ended up um
they did a um like a negotiation with us
and they did a 1099-c
and said they'd settle for this much and
we would have to pay on the taxes on the
ballot
why did you not bankrupt it
well
because we
ended up
not
doing that well i i really don't know my
husband was the one that was okay he was
fine i'm just curious because it was a
debt you could have put in the
bankruptcy but all right next question
next question and i really appreciate
you taking your time to come on the air
and tell this because as you said every
time any of us do something dumb it's a
little bit we're a little bit ashamed
that we did it and and i appreciate you
having the courage to say because my
whole show's about all the dumb things
i've done and i don't want you guys to
do them anymore okay so
i tell all my dirty laundry on here but
it's harder to tell yours and i
appreciate you doing that so let me ask
you this i'm really curious i'm not
trying to be smart alec okay
uh
when you go in there
and you say i'm gonna sit there for 90
minutes that's one hour and a half
what advice would you give to someone
that did that and then the second hour
and the third hour and the fourth hour
roll around
why did you stay in the room why did you
not break the glass and run out into the
street
they kept leaving so because it was like
i'm not rude or anything you know what
i'm saying okay so they were playing
social games on you to keep you make it
weird for you to just walk out on them
you would have had to have been a jerk
in your mind
just to watch my mind
even though they were being jerks and
holding you on so they oh yeah they use
a social mechanism to hold you
right exactly interesting so now i would
say no don't don't even go
don't even do the 90 minutes don't go in
the tiger cage yeah and like i said it
was before dave and and so we're we're
thinking to ourselves they said leave it
to your grandkids who wants to leave
their grandkids with debt who wants to
leave their grandkids with a curse
why i curse you my child
exactly i leave you with westgate i'll
leave you with westgate the funniest
part is it went from a hundred bucks for
90 minutes to 100 bucks for five hours
you could have done better delivering
pizzas
right and you got called a terrible
grandma and you got called a terrible
grandma
i mean
that you can call me a lot of stuff
don't question my papa dave
don't call me a terrible grandpa poor
luanne they're preying on the nice
people dave that's what's happening
that's the problem that's why i would
have left i'm not one of them
for you dave they're going after the
louisville i'm not one of the nice
people i have social boundaries i would
have said
i'm leaving thank you i'm good or
something to that effect
the tiger cage open the door we're
leaving
oh my goodness gracious
time shares let's hear your story
825-5225
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one guy in the business calls them crime
shares
i love that that's pretty good clever
you could call them air shares
because it's a share of air they're
selling little blocks of air that don't
really exist because you don't really
get a title
when you buy a time share you don't
really have any ownership anything and
when you go to use it that proves it
because you can't get your share of the
air that you bought
so it's air shares i like that and it
sounds like something apple would
release
you know and they could probably get
away with it
um but apparently a bunch of people have
gotten away with it so one of the folks
we've been talking to in the industry is
a
a real activist he's an attorney named
christian wah
and uh
what is happening is that several of the
timeshare companies an attorney gets a
hold of a customer that has been screwed
they go to the timeshare company and
says you're going to release this
customer because your presentation was
fraudulent
you lied
and the timeshare industry lets them go
exits them that's what it's called in
the business from the timeshare
and uh once that attorney does that two
or three times well then the timeshare
business gets pissed off and they sue
that attorney
and they these a lot of these attorneys
are small operators they're you know you
know whatever
town and so a group of them have been
sued out of business the attorneys have
been
these are attorneys that you know they
just overrun them with these billions of
dollars of uh
revenue that they have in just asking
them to do this stuff and taking control
of them so christian has put christian
wise put a bunch of them together and is
counter-suing on behalf of the attorneys
that have gotten run out of business so
we wanted to talk to him talk to him
once before on this subject but that is
that a fair summary of what's going on
christian
yeah it's a pretty good summary dave how
are you doing today great man how you
doing i'm living the dream just out of
newborn and uh i'm not gonna let her buy
any timeshares
a brand new baby congratulations
thank you very much that is awesome i'm
happy for you okay so talk about this
business you've had a lot of interaction
with their legal teams uh with their
leadership teams and deposition and in
everything else
yeah i mean they've got dozens of cases
uh they're against these exit companies
they're against the lawyers who work
with the exit companies
you do appear on the radar if you start
representing time share owners enough
and if you start having some success
and it's because some of these
developers they're adopting what they
call this
zero tolerance policy
and they kind of make up this idea that
the lawyers are just frivolously telling
everyone to stop paying on their
financing as if every time share owner
is deliriously happy with their
timeshare only when they meet this
lawyer do they suddenly wake up and say
i've got a problem you know when it's
really the complete reverse these people
are desperately unhappy they'll pay
almost any amount of money to get out of
these
crazy you call them crime shares i mean
it's not a good product and they're
desperate to change the marketing on
this and in order to do that they're
trying to push these lawyers out of
business
wow and so how many of these attorneys
have been hit so hard that they've come
to you to represent them
as a group
well i currently represent
you know gosh several
two of the best ones are scott
montgomery and todd newcomb in missouri
their law firm montgomery newcomb and i
think you've talked to scott before we
had him on the phone on the phone last
time we did the hour yeah listen he's
got a class action lawsuit against blue
green right now and it represents
between
12 and 25 000 class members
what a great target for blue green to
aim at right this guy who's had some
success certifying a class with a
legitimate complaint against this big
developer 5 000
up to 25 000 i think they're still
figuring out the number and now but
regardless you know if the minimum is 12
000 think about that i mean
so of course he's a target and so that
lawsuit's still going um the class
action is still going we have to see how
it shakes out
wow
absolutely amazing
so one of the things that you and i have
talked about is that
the attorney general down in arizona
went after
diamond resorts and hit them for what
was it 800 grand or
penalty
and uh and really you know slapped them
pretty hard for their misbehavior in the
state of arizona why aren't the
attorneys general going after the time
shares as a matter of fact one guy up in
washington's actually going after the
timeshare exit guys like he like he's i
don't know like maybe the attorney
general got a bunch of donations for his
campaign from the timeshare people why
would you support the timeshare people
go after the exit guys but this
washington ag is doing that he's going
the opposite direction
i can't vouch for the washington ag on
that or any number of things that the
washington age is doing but i can tell
you
heck i've got in front of me the florida
attorney general went after
blue green back in 2012 and actually
ordered they as part of their little
settlement blue green had to pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars create
a fund to help people who complained so
there's president for this even in
florida where my main office is
and that's like timeshare heaven
it is yeah well think about that i mean
whatever i'm not sure which yeah right
if it can be done here in florida where
these timeshare companies are super
powerful it can be done anywhere
yeah that's where the queen of
versailles lives right florida that you
got it yeah and david's wife the did you
did you see the movie yes that's
westgate oh my goodness that was
fascinating yeah they were single right
yeah
well from a purely polit i mean forget
the legalities of it we're obviously
right on the law that consumers are
getting
you know really harmed by these
developers
but just from politics it's it's a real
wonder that the attorney generals aren't
you know figuring out that they can get
votes this way yeah if you came out
helping the consumer right with the
timeshare industry's misbehavior as an
attorney general that should be big
political points
as opposed to i'm going to support the
timeshare industry and go after the exit
companies
these are everyday folks right i mean
these are not the upper class who are
buying these timeshare interests these
are the massive voters these are people
with lower middle class incomes who work
hard every day and i think it would be a
great political idea but of course
you know i'm not a politician that's an
interesting point they don't prey on the
rich no we just talked to luanne in
little rock
yeah she was broke and they went after
her yeah exactly it's the least educated
it's the
formally educated i mean you know forget
but you know the least
well-off that they prey on and you know
i'm reminded if
if this was done in the 19 you know
you'll have to pardon the comparison
back in the 1950s 1960s they went after
the naacp in all these states to try and
kick out the lawyers why because they
were helping the people who needed it
the most now
what about these consumers it's it's
it's a different you know it's not about
race but it is about economics it is
about power
and these these consumers are getting
just shafted yeah
and what's interesting too is the i
think the business is
probably over the next 20 years will die
off
because the uh the age
of the user is dying off and they're
having a real problem getting the
younger person to come in and fall for
this you're right about that yeah yeah
so i mean it's like the uh older and
they do prey on the elderly they've
always done that like they'll take
entire busloads diamonds is known for
doing that entire bus loads in from the
nursing home to try to get people to buy
it from the retirement community
so yeah there you go and then windham uh
wyndham used to be kind of like a high
not you know when i thought of a windham
hotel i thought that was a nice hotel
but they've kind of damaged their brand
because they become more timeshare than
they have
uh hotel and so now they're changing
their name huh
they did i mean now they're trying to go
by travel and leisure and i think the
main reason being that this is my
speculation that windham's brand is so
damaged by what they're doing in time
shares yep
yeah and i think marriott may run into
the same thing
marriott has traditionally run some very
nice hotel properties and the staffing
at those local hotels we've worked with
all over the nation excellent but the
leadership team at the top of marriott
oh nasty bad people we've had real
problems with them and now we're
starting to see their time share stuff
spike up as well and so that kind of
explains that christian wah thanks for
hanging out with us for a segment here
thanks so much christianwa attorney from
florida representing attorneys who get
sued by the timeshare business because
they sued the timeshare people
just in case you're wondering how
circular this is so bizarre
[Music]
[Music]
it's a time share theme hour or as a
friend of mine in the business calls it
crime shares if i can figure out a way
to call them air shares
it's like an air chair though yeah
that's i don't know it's not quite i
like the crime chair more workshop i
wish i had said it yeah who invented it
uh this guy in the business he's a big
guy he's uh one that one of the
timeshare haters now
he's going after him so he calls them
crime shares he says it's the largest
or actually christian wall said that um
in a different broadcast he said it's
the largest
legalized fraud in america today
online has been in colorado springs hey
ben tell us your story about crime
shares
absolutely they're horrible long before
we met you we learned the definition of
gullible
so
so that was back in 2004 my wife and i
actually were invited to uh vail
colorado
to a timeshare with sheridan mountain
vista
uh weston vacation group which
eventually got
purchased by marriott oh lord you got
marriott
yeah we didn't know that at the time oh
mary um
but they invited us to stay at a nice
hotel which was actually the roach motel
we walked across the street the next day
and it was just us it was just my wife
and i
we got to do an entire tour of the whole
place
it had a really nice chair lift for
winter skiing and everything like that i
was sold
and
we come to find out
through this whole process
that it's going to be horrible
but of course we don't think about it
until three days after we purchase
in the process of this i was thinking
about this i ended up getting the
disclosure statement i have it in front
of me
this is this is
blowing my mind we thought we were only
paying a thousand dollars for an every
other year even year
event one thousand dollars
seven thousand eight hundred ninety
seven dollars you thought you were
paying one thousand
we thought we were paying seven thousand
oh seven thousand okay all right
it has a 16.75
apr
we were going to be paying 17 000 you
financed air okay i did we did
we did and we thought we were smart
because we paid it off two years early
well you were smart to do that
in the sense that you got rid of
seventeen percent oh my god and we
hadn't we hadn't even learned about you
guys yet wow but
after day three
after day three
we tried calling back to sheridan and
they said i'm sorry our buyback option
is on three days not four
you have to be you're stuck with it
of course we were horrified
we didn't know what the next two years
were going to bring let alone what the
next 14 years that we actually owned it
and never used it
so where what's the status with marriott
uh
today well they they
we don't have any association with them
anymore we use the timeshare exit team
style
group we used lone star transfer okay to
get out
and uh used an exit team an exit team
called lone star that got you out
yes okay and it worked but it was a lot
longer than i wanted
and it still cost a lot of money yeah it
costs a lot of money to get out yeah
once you're in yeah
so it was it was pretty scary but less
than if you stay in yeah
yeah so so the roach roach motel
yeah
that should have been your first clue
right and it wasn't but it it was a nice
hotel just going into the sheraton
mountain vista it was even better at the
sheridan mountain vista
[Music]
so they had connections yeah okay but uh
we were smart enough to actually do our
debt free screen go with you guys in in
february of 2019. hey
yes congratulations you actually
yeah we got out
with a piece of paper saying
you know we still have our skin
yeah we got out
in june of 2019. we already paid off
everything in 2012 so that's when you
got divorced from marriott
yes i hated it because every year we had
over 600 in fees
yeah and we never wins yeah
oh
wow great story man thanks for sharing
it that is a typical time share story
this is why i don't understand why
people would buy them at all but i mean
hey i don't understand some of the dumb
things i've done too so i'm not going to
pick on you about the dumb things you
guys have done i just want to celebrate
them with you and you and i together
celebrating dumb things that we have
done can keep other people from doing
dumb things sounds like a plan what do
you think yeah have you ever bought a
timeshare no i almost fell for the
presentation because i got we got lured
into the spa day on the honeymoon and i
thought no way spending three hours with
this woman no thank you not my wife let
me make that clear let me make that very
clear
it was the time to sound like you're
referring to whitney god bless you she's
working on floor five now going oh my
gosh go down there hilarious i'm going
down there but you know what it made me
think of you know it's easier to get a
divorce than it is to get out of a
timeshare that's backwards
it's easy to get divorced in america
than it is to get out of a timeshare
think about that first and in most cases
less expensive 100
at least the legal fees
[Laughter]
thomas you don't have to split assets
with marriott when you get rid of them
but it costs you a lot more than the
legal fees uh hypothetically thomas and
dayton tom tells your timeshare story
guys i had uh
i feel a lot better now because i paid
them a thousand dollars it back and they
agreed that's a good deal
uh i was so happy to pay that thousand
dollars absolutely you got a bar good
news was we had a place in maui okay now
if you're gonna have a time share maui
sounds good i hope it's in maui yeah
amen
and and i don't want to sound like a
snob because
because i think you'll understand what i
mean you can only go one place so many
times
and and i won't say we're tired of maui
but we bought it 20 years ago
and
i tried for the last 10 years to give it
away and i could not get anybody to take
it from me for free no one would take
your heir
no one would take it
uh they changed the rules on us
uh these people are good i mean they're
much better at their job
you don't mean
you don't mean morally you mean slick
i mean they're good at their job they're
good at getting your signature on that
dotted line screwing you yeah absolutely
absolutely which company which company
was your maui time share with
i'd rather not say because they have not
i sent them the thousand dollars but
they haven't sent me back the letter
that said you're clear oh okay they're
listening right now
they are listening it's one of the big
ones
i promise you they're listening so don't
say
yeah i i i when i get my letter back
quite uh
you can you can tell us another time tom
it's okay
earlier yeah tell us what it rhymes with
no don't i'm just i'm telling you
they're monitoring this broadcast i
promise you one day we've already gotten
feedback i promise you it's okay you
just stay right where you are
i was at the hotel my wife and i and we
i was coming up from the pool in the
elevator this i'm mentioning this
because
you suggested it to luanne a little
while ago i was coming up in the
elevator and it was obvious i was in the
elevator with a salesman and two
prospects
and the prospective couple the husband
looked at me and said are you an owner
and i said yes sir
and he said
what do you think
and i paused and i
i just
looked at him and
run
the salesman's jaw hit his chest
and i just said hey he asked
and the elevator door opened and i left
and here's my name if you want to exit
me for free you can call me this tonight
i'll never do this again otherwise i'm
coming back every year and ride the
elevator
right oh believe me i thought about
putting cards through everybody's doors
saying you know don't buy i'll give it
mine free
but they just you know it's it's so hard
to exchange they tell you how easy it is
to exchange well you can exchange it
for a less desirable destination in the
off season anytime you want yeah well
tom i hope the thousand dollars goes
through for you because we won't reveal
who you're what your real name is bob
i mean henry secretary i mean george i
mean no you're george wait i'm sorry
you're dave
wow this is fun in the worst way we're
gonna yeah it's a sick kind of fun that
we have here on the ramsey show but
occasionally we have to do this just to
let you guys know there are things out
there and people out there that are out
to get you
most people trying to screw you are just
enthusiastic ignoramuses
but others are just straight up crooks
they know what they're doing
and they're here to take you down
payday lenders they're here to take you
down
yeah and crime shares
boxes of air
are right there with it you really don't
buy anything people it's not an asset
it's just a liability this is weird not
a good investment
well that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books our thanks to ben and
kelly in the booth taking care of
business i'm dave ramsey your host
that's george campbell over there we'll
be right back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ramsey personality george
campbell is my co-host today he is the
host of the fine print
on ramsey networks it is a new podcast
we launched a couple of weeks ago the
third episode dropped today we'll be
taking your calls here at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five the first episode was
how turbo tax is screwing you and the
true cost of credit card rewards was the
second one the fine prints all about
digging in and finding out what the fine
print says exactly we you know the
tagline is the hidden truths that are
keeping you broke and sometimes it's
your own financial ignorance sometimes
it's a money myth and sometimes it's a
it's a bad product it's a scummy company
like time shares like you're talking
about and so we're trying to help people
understand because there's so many
voices out there there's social media
and the headlines and my dad told me to
get an fha loan and lease a car and so
i'm trying to do the research for people
and go hey what's going on out there
what are the trends and how can i help
them avoid the traps because i found
that when you follow the trends you fall
for the traps it's an interesting
relationship now how long ago did we
record these episodes there's ten of
them yes and um i mean they obviously
went on several months building all of
them yeah but the one that dropped today
was um it kind of felt like it was a
little bit after the game but now it's
all coming back as kobe comes back how
to bulletproof your money for the next
pandemic yeah it was like we thought
well there were not going to be another
but now we got a little spike going yes
i thought well is this going to be
relevant by the time it launches and
wouldn't you know it dave we've got the
variant people are starting to freak out
again and they're starting to go oh crap
i need to get my financial situation in
order because we don't know what's going
to happen and you know grandma said it's
going to rain and so we need we need a
rainy day fund we need an umbrella and
so in this episode we talked to real
people we talked to a woman named julie
who lost her job
she faced homelessness and here's her
quote having debt is a vulnerable
lifestyle and she said that with with
tears you could hear her voice shaking
because of how frustrated she was she
was with her own situation we talked to
famed economist dr art laffer who talked
us through what happened with the cares
act and what the government's role
should be when it comes to a pandemic
and i compared it to a drunk guy at a
party he he shows up he breaks things
and you go shouldn't have invited that
guy and that's kind of what happens when
when the government starts to get
involved and they're trying to help and
they go well we're a few trillion on the
government is the drunk guy at the party
that's what happens he broke grandma's
heirloom lamp and we got who invited
this guy i didn't ask him to show up and
so we walk people through them are your
friends who don't know how to vote
properly yeah oh my goodness yes and
here's the thing with these podcasts
dave a lot of people go i don't have
room for another podcast this is a 19
minute episode and we're releasing these
every other week and it's narrative it's
storytelling the feedback on the on the
style has been really encouraging people
are really gravitating towards it it hit
number one in business uh the whole
launch week we even beat i don't want to
say it we beat the ramsay show
temporarily just for one
one moment you know beating it
temporarily gives me great pride beating
it a lot yeah starts to make me worried
well it's your job it's your fault
because you talk about it on air and
people go okay i'll go listen to it
so it's really your fault that we beat
you well the good news is i own it so i
feel better now that's fair yeah i feel
better already go listen to this thing
you can go to fineprintpodcast.com you
can search for the fine print wherever
you listen to podcasts like you said
we've got three episodes out right now
we've got seven more to go in season one
and it's only 19 minutes and it's really
i'm hoping it helps people go have that
oh crap moment the never again moment
the i'm going to draw a line in the sand
moment i'm going i'm going to get that
emergency one in place because i don't
want to live vulnerably anymore yeah
what we say around here is be the third
pig
there were the three little pigs
one built his house out of straw one out
of sticks and when the big bad wolf came
the pandemic came he huffed and he
puffed and he blew their house down
they all ran where to their brother who
they made fun of earlier
because he lived like no one else so
that later he could live and give like
no one else and he lived in a brick
house
and when the big bad wolf came he said
you three little pigs come out and they
said not by the hair of our
chinny chin chin that's the one thank
you very much for that queue very good
and uh that's what you say to the
pandemic yeah i'm not coming out i've
got i i got
i got you know what happens with money
is everybody's mad about money until
they need some
everybody's all philosophical about
money's evil until they need some and
when you need some is when you need to
put margin between you in danger
you an inconvenience
you and hunger
and money it's not money is no use it's
not it's not worth anything except what
it does
and in a pandemic or a situ or a
personal tragedy or personal crisis it
doesn't have to be a nationwide thing if
you're the third pick
the little pig in the brick house
it puts you in a completely
different mindset
um because you're thinking you know mr
wolfe
i think i got
i i think you might be in more danger
than i'm in um you start to turn the
tables on them when you're in a
different position yeah you know it
because you've prepared
now people made fun of you
yeah you're doing that dave ramsey stuff
don't you know that's a cult you know
you're doing that stuff you know you're
bible stuff you're like one of those
christians what are you crazy you know
people always all these broke people
have an opinion but be the third pick
live on lesson you make save money have
an emergency fund be out of debt you got
20 000 in the bank and no debt at all of
any kind and a pandemic comes you're in
a different place
or a tragedy of some kind comes to your
life it changes everything oh yeah and
i've been working on so we're covering
baby step three at our financial peace
accelerated event and so i've been doing
all this research on the emergency fund
and baby step three and it's fascinating
to me the amount of financial peace you
get you know you get out of debt and
you're still not quite there no you
still are vulnerable yes and once you
get that emergency fund in place it
changes everything it takes the drama
out of life and all the crazy stuff and
you talk about this it's funny when you
get an emergency fund you stop having
emergencies
and life gets a little easier because
not everything is an emergency anymore
well it takes the drama out i mean like
during the pandemic i had a lot of
stress but my stress was self-created
because i have a thousand people here
that i didn't want them to lose their
jobs and i'm responsible as a leader
that was leadership the stress but i
don't have any financial stress
because technically speaking i would
never want to do this but i mean if it
went really sideways i could send all of
them home all this is paid for
i don't have any payments i'll be okay
you know
and so i don't want to do that it seemed
really unproductive and you know it
would break my heart in so many ways but
this idea that
peace financial peace having an
emergency fund in place it changes
everything yeah and we're looking at the
stats here we covered this in the
podcast but it's sad 40 of americans
can't pay for a 300 emergency in cash 50
don't have a thousand dollars in their
savings account and if we can bump up
one percentage point because people
listen to this podcast and go all right
i got to do something differently third
pick baby be the third pig and so it's
called how to bulletproof your money for
the next pandemic you can get it for
free wherever you listen to podcasts you
can go to findprintpodcast.com
and check it out and really the hope is
that we can help to uncover some of the
stuff to help the people out there make
smarter decisions with their money yeah
life is coming it's coming endemic or
otherwise get you an umbrella it's
coming
be the third
pig
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peak real estate season is here this
year things are different home prices
are higher competition between buyers is
intense and sellers need to know what
they're doing if they're going to make
the most out of the sale of their home
you don't want to play amateur hour in
this mess don't jump head first into
something you don't understand you need
to get advice from a pro who's done this
before like hundreds and hundreds of
times this being sell a house connect
with one of our endorsed local providers
they are high octane high protein agents
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent
ronnie is with us
and hannah and they are in new orleans
hey guys how are you
hey we are good god i see on my screen
you're debt-free how much have you paid
off
uh we paid off 236 thousand dollars all
right how long did this take you
about 30 months good for you and your
range of income during that time
uh we started out at about 60 000 and we
went up to about 360.
oh good lord what do y'all do for a
living
uh we're both in the medical field oh so
one of you graduated from med school and
took off huh
yeah well both of us both of you did oh
okay so is this med school debt you were
paying off
yeah um it was my medical school debt
and then um my husband didn't have any
debt with medical school how come
i just came from a
lucky family my from my standpoint
it was all paid off by my family
apparently i'll call it blessed i need
that kind of luck i was gonna say i
don't think luck had anything to do with
it but yeah good very good all right so
you're both mds
yes
all right way to go no this is awesome
and you decided to do this very quickly
in two and a half years why
um well it was kind of a long time
coming we um
so i got we got your book when we were
married in 2013
we read it loved it and we put it right
back on the shelf and we did not follow
that plan
so
five years later a family member was
having some financial financial problems
and i was like oh i have a book for you
and then i realized that my medical
school loans had gone from 170 000 to
230 000 in just five years because of
the interest
so we decided that that was the time to
start paying it off so maybe the people
with the financial problems were you
[Laughter]
so you sit down and have the
conversation get the book back off the
shelves is that how this works
yeah pretty much ronnie yeah hannah kind
of spearheaded a lot of it um
you know read it started going through
the system and
seemed like a lot of steps and uh you
know my first reaction was you know it's
a lot of work doing all the budgeting
and
you know the cash envelopes and
i had always been coming from a
background i was like i just go with the
flow and we'll just pay it off as we go
uh but then
i i'll say it i'm married into some of
this death though
so we
we just started doing it bit by bit and
then we dove right in
and uh
yeah eventually we were doing it 100
were your families questioning your
sanity or cheering you on
uh
it wasn't really a
big public decision there were
definitely conversations where
uh
you know i would talk about oh you know
we're not using credit cards anymore and
everyone would be like well that's crazy
oh what about all these points
and uh you know you get like cash back
and all these things and honestly like
from a gut standpoint i was like yeah
that's true i am missing out on all
these points but then you know we stuck
with the system and didn't get lulled
into that
you know temptation of all those things
because the psychological aspect of all
that and uh so there are naysayers but
you know here we are
yeah my one of my friends who was in
naysayer was actually i would constantly
call her and be like look what we just
did and look what we just paid off and
she's like god y'all are so crazy
wow do you guys have friends that are
that are uh docs like you guys and
they're going wait what are you doing
you should be buying nice cars you
should be living it up
yeah pretty much everyone yeah oh my
goodness like buying million dollar
homes and hundred thousand dollar cars
yep yep
that's what's going on and you realized
i'm paying 60 000 in interest you said
it went from 170 to 230.
yeah that doesn't sound like good debt
to me
no that wasn't good i thought student
loans are good debt dave i was i'm
confused
just blew my mind
you guys are incredible what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
um i say um the
budgeting
weekly like and just checking in all the
time
and having like a goal in mind for the
end
wow
good for you well well done how's it
feel to be free
it feels pretty good yeah still got some
work to do but at this point the uh
the being debt-free aspect has been
a huge relief and a big step
however
yeah yeah well you're making a lot of
money now you get to keep it that's a
good thing yeah plus or minus some taxes
right yeah well done
all right well ronnie hannah we got
we're real proud of you guys well done
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you and that of course uh is the next
chapter in your story to completely
change your legacy you've got the income
to do that and the outgo is not all
going out anymore i love it and of
course copy the total money makeover for
you to give to someone else ronnie and
hannah new orleans 236 000 paid off in
30 months making 60 to 360. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
ready
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
jovanna is with us in new york newark
new jersey hey giovanna what's up
hi
um
how you doing good how can we help
yes so um i am
all in with your uh with your principles
and i am a host for the financial piece
so far twice this year and will be my
next
next class in october
but i must admit i am feeling very
discouraged um because um i don't have
any debt um and um i'm coming out of a
22 year marriage and i've always been a
stay-at-home mom and a homeschool mom
and so here i am trying to get an
apartment and they're wanting credit how
you get how do you get an apartment if
you don't have credit i don't want a
credit card i i don't want anything to
do with that but i feel discouraged
because how can i
get
something without credit how many of you
actually talked to
um yeah a lot actually just was going on
realtor.com and um did you actually call
the apartment complex and talk to the
manager
not the manager but the person that
would actually um answer the phone you
know
because we did a thing anthony o'neil
got anthony o'neil's on youtube we did a
thing he called 20 plus apartments and
said i'm i i i have no credit score
how much of a down payment or how much
of a deposit do i have to make and will
you rent to me and all of them but two
would rent to him
wow
so i'm yeah and i'm right now in new
jersey trying to move to arizona because
my son has a scholarship opportunity out
there
and
you know
and you've actually called
20 apartments
20 of 20 rentals in arizona or you just
looked on realtor.com no oh no i haven't
called i haven't called 20. i just you
know i've called three
uh that is within my price range yeah
three is not enough to get discouraged
but i haven't i haven't spoke to the
manager so maybe that's why just call
them and say you have a job right
i don't
well
honey that's why they don't care if
you've got a credit score or not they're
going to rent to you without a job
right so like i said my my situation is
a little bit odd um like i said 20 22
yeah but it's not your credit score it's
a problem
i'll rent to you without a credit score
as a as a landlord i do all the time but
i'm not going to rent to you if you
don't have a job
right so i mean my income my income is
only in child support so i do have that
as my answer i'm not writing to you on
alimony child support because he's not
dependable
okay gotcha i have to know you can pay
the rent as the landlord yeah they're
not true for income it's not your credit
score plus you've only actually talked
to three
you're not allowed to get discouraged
when you talk to three and that's your
sample size talk to 30
tell them what's going on maybe one of
them will run to you with child support
and alimony
if you can live on that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage todd and ashley
are with us hey guys how are you doing
good welcome where do you guys live san
jose california wonderful and how much
debt have you paid off 305
512.88 love it how long did this take
three years and nine months
goodness gracious and your range of
income during that time about 165 to
about 280. cool what do y'all do for a
living i'm a pediatrician and i'm an
engineer in the medical device field wow
great careers obviously great incomes
but obviously a lot of debt
so i'm guessing uh maybe a little school
debt in that
all student debt every bit of it all of
it three hundred and six thousand
dollars yep
so uh how long you guys have been
married
coming up on four years now uh in
november okay so right after the
marriage you looked down and you went oh
my god yeah this just got real just
before we got married and we had been
kind of talking about the debt that i
mostly had
med school dad of course med school debt
yep exactly
and so you sat down and said oh we got
to do something about this tell us the
story what happened so it actually
started a couple months before we got
married i was on one of my last
rotations in medical school i was
working with some paramedics and we were
up late one night just kind of hanging
out at the station and he was talking to
me about the student debt that he had um
a conversation that i would say i had
several times throughout my training
with you know different physicians
nurses of various levels
and usually the conversation would end
yeah i have a lot too oh well
um and this conversation was a little
bit different he mentioned your name and
he said that he was actively working um
picking up a lot of shifts which he can
do in his field to work on his debt in
your name ranga bell so i realized my
dad had talked about you my entire life
um so financial peace baby yeah exactly
um hadn't always followed the steps
until more recently which has been
exciting to see them go through it too
but yeah that night i basically started
googling your name pulled up your
podcast and
usually when i find something i go 100
in so i did and i basically downloaded
every podcast that would fit on my phone
oh my gosh
listen to them just back to back to back
wow um
yeah and then pretty much came to todd
with hey i know you were really afraid
of all the debt you're
marrying into but
just been brainwashed by this podcast
oh my gosh and todd what'd you say
you know it took me a little bit to get
on board uh you know like she said she's
100 and when she goes in and so you know
she encouraged me to listen to some
podcasts i kind of have to come to
things on my own and so it took not very
long though it took me a couple weeks i
started to listen to some of your
podcasts and um you know i'm a logical
guy i'm an engineer and it all just made
perfect sense to me and you know i was
i've never been to every in my life my
parents always had that you know gave me
a wonderful childhood but you know the
debt was kind of always looming my
entire life so i had no idea what being
debt-free was like um and so you know i
wanted a plan it was one of those things
you just kind of push it off to the side
and you just think we're gonna be able
to make enough money to pay this off at
some point um but definitely my heart
sank when i saw just how much loans that
she had but um so i was i was
enthusiastic that she actually you know
found a plan that we could work together
and so
you know i was 100 on board once i
started to kind of learn more about your
program because when you first hear the
amount you go
uh that's going to take a while
yeah
and you did it in three years and nine
months when you did you
when you first were sitting down look at
this did you dream you could do it that
fast
no we initially planned five years when
we kind of laid it all out
and i had done all my training i'm from
texas and was moving out to california
for more training so the thought of
paying california rent prices and still
being in training and doing this plans
and taxes exactly yeah all kinds of
different stuff yeah and extra cost of
living really right so
san jose is not cheap it's not
definitely not so it was hard to
estimate those costs um and i think you
know we made a good plan it was five
years and
typical ashley form i was like i want to
do it in four i think that sounds better
than five years and so we got a little
bit more aggressive and then as you get
towards the end it just it truly
snowballs and that's how we were able to
even tick off a couple more months to
make it under four years which was
really exciting yeah i mean clearly you
guys lived on less than you make but
what were the sacrifices that you guys
had to do to keep this thing more and
more aggressive
a lot of trips right you know a lot of
our friends coming straight out of
school
you know i was in grad school out at
texas when we met and so i had friends
that had just finished their phd
programs too and she was having friends
right after residency in med school that
we're doing a lot of really fun
traveling a lot of really fun eating out
and there was just a lot of stuff we had
to say no to and so we kind of go on a
lot of those trips it was kind of the
time in our lives when a lot of our
friends were getting married too so we
had to say no to a lot of weddings
bachelor parties bachelorette parties
that sort of thing
but yeah that was i think pretty hard so
some fomo there you're scrolling on
instagram while you're eating rice and
beans going oh man look they just went
on that trip look like they have fun
over there but you guys had uh the jomo
mentality which is what i call the joy
of missing out because you had bigger
priorities you had bigger plans for your
life and you knew this was a temporary
sacrifice to set you up for the future
exactly that's incredible yeah man you
guys are awesome who were your biggest
cheerleaders i'm guessing your dad yeah
definitely both of our parents so my dad
was really excited when i brought up
your name and he was like oh yeah he's
great we've never been able to fully
jump on board but he's great
um
you should do that
so they actually done it but you should
do it yeah so they actually jumped on
board and were able to get out of debt
themselves through during our journey
and todd's parents are doing the same
and it's been really fun just to see our
families cheer us along and and get on
board so i have siblings as well with
you know debt of various types who are
getting really excited to do so
our friends were great you know
especially having friends in our careers
where they were doing fun trips and they
were eating out and they wanted to have
us out with them and
they thought we were weird but they were
absolutely supportive and that really
made it easy and we made ways to you
know cook meals from our home and have
friends over or vice versa and that
definitely made it easier yeah that's a
good friend yeah we can be obnoxiously
passionate about the program too so we
had a lot of people just kind of come on
board too where they'd see us do it for
so long that you know we had a few
friends also get deb free before we did
because they had a little bit lower load
my parents are credit card debt for you
for the first time and wow you know 33
years and wow wow um definitely we've
been feeling the ripple effects too so i
love it i'm so proud of you guys look at
you evangelizing it i love it yeah
that's fun very fun okay
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of that is
uh for me it was the budget i really
loved crunching the numbers and doing
the budget and i think seeing it on
paper every month made it easier when we
had to say no
and it made it easier when we wanted to
make decisions of adjusting the budget
each you know month we had a decision
and when we had that end goal in mind it
made it easier when i could see it on
paper and see the progress month to
month so i think the budget was really
the key and continues to be the key even
as we're out of debt to kind of track
everything coming in and everything
going out yeah because now you can live
and give like no one else i mean you're
in a position of incredible incomes
and no going nowhere but up and uh of
course no no payments at all so i have a
theory um
because i do truly believe that personal
finance is 80 behavior 20 of knowledge
and i i've spent the last 25 years
trying to get people to adhere to or
submit to
a proven
process a system
and i kind of have noticed it's not
always true but i've kind of noticed
that professions
who require you in your discipline to
adhere
like medicine and engineering
you know you there's not really there's
there's a way to build a bridge that it
will fall and there's a way to build a
bridge that it will stay up in
engineering right i mean there's a way
to treat a known disease with a known
treatment program and there's a way you
don't do it and you don't like make up
your own deal you know you so you submit
to the process and the patient has to
submit to the process the client that
you're designing something in the
engineering world has to submit to the
process otherwise it's going to freaking
not work you know and i think people
that do what you do you see something
like we do and you go oh i'm doing it
yeah
because it doesn't sound like you guys
had a lot of angst about well i kind of
need to reinvent this i'm like an artist
you know you're like nope doing it do
the plan yeah right yeah i think it gave
us encouragement i mean looking at the
number to start with was just so
overwhelming and to have a plan that
kind of breaks it down little by little
i mean we could initially pay off you
know really really small student loans
and just see it snowball well done you
guys we got to copy the legacy journey
for you and total money makeover as well
306 000 paid off in three years and nine
months making 165 to 280 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two
one incredible i love it this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you wake up this morning realize you
had 306 000 in student loan debt or 236
000 in student loan debt that was our
last two
debt free
screams maybe you just woke up and you
thought i have a lot of debt or i have a
lot of problems or i don't know what i'm
doing with money you know what that
would make you normal
but normal is not good normal is not fun
normal scares you
normal keeps you up at night you don't
be normal
so if you want to decide this is the
last month you're going to be normal
i want to get out of debt i want to
build wealth i want to be generous
this month only we're knocking 30 off a
12-month membership to our most
impactful
life-changing money products
that's ramsey plus membership with that
that's where you go if you want to go to
financial peace university that's where
you go if you want to plug into our
premium version of our budgeting tool
every dollar the world's best budgeting
app plugs into your bank and everything
this way
so you go to ramsey plus you get a free
trial
by texting trial two three three seven
eight nine
jump in there to look at financial peace
university look at every dollar look at
all the other things we have there
to help you change your entire life and
it's 30 off this month only 99.99 text
trial if you want to do a free trial to
33
789 patrick is with us in fort myers
florida hi patrick welcome to the ramsey
show
hi how you doing better than i deserve
what's up in your world uh basically i'm
trying to see if i can justify myself a
new crack
okay
my wife and i basically we live on our
paychecks not counting our investments
and i'm looking at a forty five thousand
dollar truck
why currently we have
currently we have
zero good except for the mortgage
on my home
and a two-year fully funded emergency
fund
okay
along with that i've been doing extra
payments on my current truck which i
bought in 2006.
i fully paid that off and i continued
making payments and have a
savings account of approximately
eighty-two thousand dollars
well number one rule is the number one
rule when you're getting ready to buy
cars can you pay cash for it and the
answer is obviously you can pay cash for
it is this a new truck
no it's actually about 2007
okay
all right
um
and the other the other thing we tried
the other rule of thumb we use patrick
is that the thing the largest thing we
all buy that goes down in value
is a car
and things that go down in value
defeat
our wealth building plan they work
against us to build wealth obviously if
they're going down in value and so we
try to not to put too much into things
that are going down in value because the
goal here is to build wealth so that you
can drive anything you want to drive and
not have to worry about it and so the
rule we've used for yours is don't buy
things with motors and engines all added
together that's more than half your
annual income and this is
well actually when i say that's my
annual income that's just what we live
on it's not counting all the revenue we
get from the business that we own as
well with our original income well then
that's not your income
what is your annual income
my annual income is 382 000.
okay well then you can afford a 45 000
truck if you pay cash for it as long as
the other car is not a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar vehicle
the other car is already paid off anyway
it doesn't matter if it's paid off if
it's a lamborghini you can't have the
truck but otherwise you can get the
truck yeah i mean here because you know
you got plenty of money
it's not it's not your salaried income
it's the income the point is we're
trying to measure and say is this are
you putting too much of your life in
things that are going down in value when
you have a three hundred thousand dollar
income and eighty thousand dollars in
the bank to buy the thing with
forty five thousand is not too much of
your life yeah absolutely i mean that
those numbers change everything when i
thought you were making 73 and you want
to buy a 46 000 truck i mean that's
that's insane but based on the numbers
you just shared with us this is a fine
move i would question you know are you
is this just a fun toy i mean you guys
have worked really hard you said you had
a two-year emergency fund yeah it's a
little steep
you guys go all in on whatever it is so
it sounds like he's going all in on this
truck and you have the money for it i
don't see a problem with that
yeah and i would adjust your emergency
fund to six months and invest the
difference or put it under your mortgage
if you've got a mortgage still so um
those are the kinds of things but if you
make 300 000 a year and you have the
money to pay cash for 45 000 truck and
it's not brand new
no problem if it is brand new and your
net worth is over a million no problem
do it you know that's still just fine
cara's in san diego hi cara welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave it's an honor to talk to you
today you too what's up
really cool um so i'm looking at
updating my health insurance my husband
and i are trying to start a family this
year
and i'm a little fed up with
just how health insurance is going with
us looking into hsas and at face value
it seems like the hsa is more expensive
than my current plan and i'm wondering
what i'm missing
the hsa is typically a
a cheaper premium
a higher deductible and typically
they're 100 pay after the deductible is
that what yours is
um at face value from what i'm seeing
the hsa would be more per month about 30
and the out of pocket max is also more
than what i pay now which is about a 4
500 out of pocket max with a
with an annual or a monthly premium that
is about what's your deductible on the
other plan
well you said the out-of-pocket max is
still more yeah
yeah everything seems more so i'm
wondering if maybe you could explain the
tax benefits because maybe that's where
i'm seeing savings is on an annual
perspective i mean you might see some
there but usually the premium is less so
that's an unusual plan you've got
is this through work i assume right
this is through cover california
oh
i have no idea what they're doing
um okay so i mean because let me tell
you in our in our corporate plan and in
most of the corporate plans in america
the hsa will be a higher deductible a
higher out of pocket
per year and so it doesn't work as well
for people who are
have chronic illness uh
you know they're constantly in there um
it works best for people who have very
little illness
okay
and so i mean if you're constantly
bumping up into that thing uh into that
deductible and it's going to end up
costing you more with an hsa but like
the ramsey family knock on wood has been
inordinately healthy and blessed in that
regard
so we almost never use our health
insurance and so what we end up with is
a basically a high deductible cheaper
premium policy at our house now uh uh
but that's you know uh so far thank you
lord but in your case i'm not positive
the tax benefit is simply whatever you
put into the savings portion
of the health savings account is tax
deductible like a traditional ira that's
the only tax savings
i see so is that something like where if
you were to invest dollars out of your
paycheck
uh
like not through an employer or
something right i would rather you max
out retirement before you start putting
in money into an hsa i would rather you
pay off your mortgage before you start
putting substantial money into your hsa
well that
actually really helps yeah so it sounds
like with your analysis of cover care
california cover care which i never
looked at i don't know the details
so uh but it sounds like based on your
analysis you would go with the not hsa
because for whatever reason the way
they've designed that uh that offering
the hsa is not cheaper which is weird
yeah i would look into the fine print on
that and contact them and have them walk
you through the numbers because i'm with
you dave i'm on the hsa here i've got
the high deductible and it's the
cheapest option yeah for monthly
premiums and so i'd be shocked if it's
more for your premium on that side so
definitely look into that there may be
something that you're not aware of or
not understanding fully so contact them
and do some research and dig into that
yeah it is california it is california
government so you don't know i mean
there's no no telling what they're doing
but um
you know once the government puts their
hands on something it's hard to tell
what's going to happen but an open
market policy with a typical company in
america
um
you're you're gonna find the hsa to be
more
a higher deductible and a lower premium
normally that's the normal plan and most
of them are again after you meet your
deductible
they have a hundred percent coverage
there's no co-pay
so your out-of-pocket is your deductible
in those cases your max out of pocket
george campbell my co-host to this hour
thanks to ben and kelly in the booth i'm
dave ramsey your host this is the ramsey
show we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today he is
the host of the fine print a newly
minted podcast out on the ramsey network
he's also the host of andre leadership
podcast with new episodes dropping every
monday the fine print is a 10 episode
podcast the third one dropped today if
you want to listen to it digging into uh
like we were told as we were kids read
the fine print yes this is just the new
school version and uh we're really
digging into all of the money myths all
of the scummy companies the bad products
the financial ignorance that's keeping
america broke so i'm on a mission to get
america unbroke if that's a thing if we
can do that i will have succeeded so
we've got these narrative storytelling
episodes coming out every other week
they're short form they're no no more
than 30 minutes today's episode is 19
minutes and we're gonna help bullet
proof your money for the next pandemic
so if that's you and you had an oh crap
moment that's the that's this one
episode of the drop today just dropped
this morning it's bulletproof your
finances bulletproof what how to
bulletproof your money the next pandemic
we might be in the next pandemic i don't
know i can't tell when one ends and the
next one starts
it's all mixing together now well yeah
it's confusing yeah but hey an emergency
fund it can change everything so we're
going to walk you through that we've got
dr art laffer the economist we've got
real life stories and really tactical
advice yeah hands-on stuff so be sure
and check it out the fine print
anywhere great podcasts are listened to
you can tune in and find it there max is
with us max is in los angeles hi max how
are you
dave how are you thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure how can we
help
real quick um i was wondering um how do
i go about finding the valuation of a
sole proprietor of a service based sole
proprietorship business i was recently
made an offer to take it over for free
not as an old friend of mine that just i
knew i was looking for a career change
and said you could have my entire
business
mainly it's service based doing home
repairs doing repairs for property
management companies um kind of handyman
construction service
and i just don't know how to even begin
to evaluate it
okay
well it um
here's the thing the the business
has a value
beyond what you would pay someone if you
were an absentee owner not working in it
to operate it
and this sounds a little bit like this
guy owns his job
more than he owns a business
right so what is his income
uh well i'm going to find out the
details a little later but i know if i
were to guess it's anywhere between
about 140 to 250 anywhere in that in
that realm probably gross revenue or net
profit
net profit
well that's pretty substantial does he
have employees
only when he needs helpers but typically
it's just him
okay
all right so here's the way you value a
business
properly in that scenario or anything
else where the owner is operating in the
business and not paying himself a
separate salary
you act like you're not going to work in
the business
okay so if you were going to just buy
this business you'd have to staff it
right
and if you staff this to do basically
what he does
then what does that cost let's just use
a pretend okay
let's pretend he's netting
a hundred thousand bucks and you can
staff it for 60. you can hire a handyman
to work for you to do the business okay
and then you're just you're just you're
an investor is all at that point
okay okay so your rate of return
is net of paying your staff if you made
a net profit before of 100 you pay some
160 to do the work your net profit would
be 40. you follow my example
yes sir that's the way we look at this
and your way you'll have to analyze it
and come down to it especially where
you're buying kind of a one-man band
uh situation because it's very you have
to be very careful there but even if he
had 10 employees if he was netting 250
but not paying himself anything
you know you got to figure out what it
takes to hire a manager to run a 10
employee operation that does home
improvement um
and that's 250 well you're probably
going to pay that guy a hundred so you
probably got 150
net profit that you would use now then
you say as an investor what do i what
kind of rate of return do i want to make
on my money well when you're buying a
small business the rate of return should
be anywhere from 20 to 25
because it's a high risk investment low
risk investments like mutual funds pay
10 11 12 real estate a little bit more
but this is a high risk investment to
buy a small business and so if i want a
20 rate of return that means i want 5x
the business is worth 5x
of the uh
net profit after staffing
or if you want a 25 it's worth 4x after
staffing so in my example of a 40 000
net profit five of that would be a 200
000 valuation
four would be a hundred and
sixty thousand dollar valuation so that
would be the range that that company
netting forty thousand dollars would be
worth
somewhere in there you value it based on
a rate of return it's called a cap rate
on the net profit 4 or 5x of that net
profit after all staffing and george
when we're working with entree leaders
uh they oftentimes say things like well
you know i have good will
i have a great brand a great reputation
in the marketplace right yep you've
heard them say i've heard that yeah and
the problem is your great reputation or
your goodwill in the marketplace is
worth zero
unless you use it to create money
if you have a great reputation and you
make no profit what your reputation is
is you're not very good at running a
business
that's actually your reputation he's a
really nice guy and he sucks at business
that's your reputation because you don't
make a profit
and so but if you make a profit the good
will the value of your brand the
notoriety of the family in the community
the whatever is only valuable to the
extent it turns money in now it has an
intrinsic value it has a philosophical
value a spiritual value a feel-good
value all of those things but none of
that has to do with the financial
calculation no and i'm worried about max
getting into a bad business deal because
it sounds like this is going to cost him
a lot of money if he buys this thing
based on the numbers he shares he said
the guy was going to give it to him i
mean if he's just handing it over i'd
question why i got i already don't want
to do it anymore he can't find anybody
to buy it and so he says hey this is
yours if you want it yeah the problem is
this guy's working his tail off it
sounds like yeah he might be working 80
hours a week and those numbers might not
be real yeah i'd want some hard numbers
on paper and go like proof look at the
old two last two years of tax returns
what'd you pay taxes on well i didn't
report it all well then we can't count
anything yeah because now we can't trust
you because you don't need because you
lie on your taxes
i just don't want this to be a lot of
work for max if he takes this thing over
and goes oh my gosh i didn't know what i
was getting into if you're looking what
we encourage people to do in ontario
leadership is don't buy a job
okay if you're gonna end up making your
income out of the thing and that's all
there is
and there's no real net profit
don't pay
to buy a job yeah just go get a job get
you one right but if you can if this
guy's gonna hand it to you and if it's
really making money and he's just tired
of it
then that's something you can certainly
look at max
very cool good discussion thanks for
calling in brother this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free free samples free shipping great
company
they run new promos all the time you
want window blinds these are the guys
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal today's question comes from
david in pennsylvania i would like to
purchase a small house my neighbor who's
a realtor says i have to have a credit
score to get a mortgage i'm 18 years old
and i'm not too sure what to do i was
inspired by you not to get a credit card
so i use debit cards or pay with cash do
i need to establish a credit score to
buy a home the age-old question well
this one's easy because i did it without
a credit score so there we go personal
testimony real life proof you are a home
owner
and you did not pay cash you got a
mortgage we got a mortgage and you did
it without a credit score and we did it
with no score wait a minute are you real
we're not real you're not real you're
performance of your imagination
this is the funniest part dave we get
this a lot and we we talk about manual
underwriting we talk about no score
loans of course our friends at churchill
mortgage do these all day long but for
some reason people go
it's so much work oh my gosh you can't
imagine how much work it is to get a
no-score loan
what did you have to do i literally had
to look up maybe three utility payments
i had to pick up maybe a few extra w-2s
and hit an upload button and i went okay
wow that was a lot of work
they didn't they didn't even verify your
employment i mean sure they they do the
basics but there was nothing crazy where
i went home you had to sign a piece of
paper saying they could email us or
check with us sure yeah we usually do a
voe a verification of employment yes and
a vod the verification the deposit at
your bank make sure you have the money
yes and a w-2 and a couple of utility
bills i don't know how you got through
all that sounds stressful oh my it took
17 years for us to get the mortgage dave
it was really it was not that big of a
deal i almost wanted it to be a bigger
deal because people made it out to be
this big deal
and so
uh david to answer your question you do
not need to establish a credit score
unless you want to play
play the game of the system and uh
you're already doing great you're you're
paying with cash you're using a debit
card so here's my advice is to you know
go with someone like a churchill
mortgage who does a no score loan manual
underwriting they call it a few
different things and here's what i would
tell you get a healthy down payment
you're 18 years old you're super young
and he's looking into getting a mortgage
and the biggest thing is to get that
healthy down payment where they go oh
this guy's got money he's got a job he
pays his bills on time we're going to
give him a mortgage that's how they did
in the olden days yeah back in the day
before before fico took over the world
uh
all right so here's the first thing
it's okay if you don't buy a house when
you're 18.
a matter of fact it's
probably better than okay
if you just take let's take your time
you're all right the second thing is
a real estate agent that does not know
about manual underwriting that you can
buy a home without
a credit score is not a credible real
estate agent this is not someone that
you would use they do not know what the
crap they're doing
so don't use your neighbor
the real estate agent yeah incompetent
and if they if they are saying uh we
can't do that it's probably because they
just don't want to go through the hassle
no it's because they don't know how yeah
and which means they're ignorant and you
don't need to buy a house from them
that's what it means
and so it's a pretty simple formula
in that regard scary
wow
hey paycheck to purpose ken coleman's
new book on pre-sale is breaking records
the amount of these books we have sold
on pre-sale blowing my mind okay the
title of the book is from paycheck to
purpose the clear path
to doing work you love it's available
pre-sale now and that includes a hundred
dollars worth of goodies it's not just
another how-to guide for finding a dream
job if you pre-order today you will
receive the get a promoted bonus pack
for free it includes an audio lesson on
promotions how to get promoted the disk
assessment a free live stream access to
kins from paycheck to purpose live event
a 30-day free trial to ramsey plus and
over a hundred dollars worth of free
stuff to help you get promoted oh man
this is a bargain offer a 20 book why
are we doing all this because the book
comes out in november and we want to
pre-sell a whole bunch of them and make
sure these comes out of the gate on the
best seller list and so we sell the crud
out of them up front and we bribe you to
buy them early with all these hundreds
and hundreds of dollars worth of stuff
extra so go to the online store
ramseysolutions.com pre-order the book
paycheck to purpose for only 20
and get these hundreds of dollars worth
of get promoted bonus items also the
month of august means cash giveaway
we're giving a 500 cash giveaway every
week and a grand prize of three thousand
dollars cash at the end of august for
the chances to win for that no purchase
necessary got to be 18 to win text cash
to 33 789 cash to 33789
scott is whether scott is in nashville
hi scott welcome to the ramsey show
hey there dude how you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
um yeah so i recently moved down to
nashville right
and i'm starting to look at purchasing
my first house
um
and being that i've never been a
salaried employee before and this is all
kind of brand new to me
i'm trying to figure out how to
prioritize my money in order to
most efficiently go about purchasing my
house
um
and
so right now
how old are you
i'm 23. good what do you what do you
make
uh so i made 42 000 a year um and then
after deductions and taxes and
everything come out it's more like 25
000 take home okay
cool
now uh i want to ask you this guy do you
have any debt right now
i got about 7 000 left um that's all on
a car note i just paid off my student
loan today good for you awesome way to
go man congratulations well here's the
deal
i love that that you're moving here and
you want to buy a house but i want you
to get rid of this debt first do you
have an emergency fund do you have any
savings right now
uh i got about 5k for the way
you have 5k saved
yeah okay so here's what we're going to
do if you're following our plan and not
scott's plan here's what i want you to
do you're going to take 4 000 of that
and pay the car down today which is
going to take you down to a thousand
right
and then we're going to get aggressive
on that remaining 3k and with your
income you should be able to crush that
within a few months and then i want you
to save up a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses and
so once you know what expenses you're
gonna have living here fill that up and
then we can talk about saving up for
this house and that's where baby step
three b comes in where we save up
aggressively for that down payment for
about two years and uh you know in that
two years you might be in good luck
because uh the market may slow down here
in nashville things are crazy right now
dave yeah so scott um
this this whole thing is new to you and
this idea of getting on a plan and
working through george just outlined for
you what we call the baby steps and it's
the baby steps the shortest distance
between where you are today and becoming
wealthy
and if you do things in a very precise
proven order you'll bring less pain to
yourself and more probability to going
into wealth and so that's what he just
outlined for you but also involved in
that is just learning how to handle
money overall and that's a brand new
subject i mean you're a young guy just
getting started first time out
first job in a new city so here's what i
want you to do
our class is financial peace university
on how to handle money
included in that is every dollar the
world's best budgeting app
the whole thing is on sale right now for
99
uh for a one-year subscription to ramsey
plus which puts you in this okay
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna give it
to you
free
okay wow thank you
however if i do that there's two
conditions number one you have to
promise me you'll actually freaking do
this stuff
yeah of course you have to actually look
at it and do it if i give it to you and
just waste it that's a bad thing
the second thing is when you're rich
someday
and you will be if you follow these
steps i want you to find a 23 year old
guy who's just getting started and i
want you to buy it for him someday
okay okay but that's that's later it's
only if everything i teach you works
okay and um you know you don't have to
pay it forward if there's nothing to pay
from yeah so i was in scott's place i
was 23 moved here started working here
and i'm rooting for them i see myself oh
and by the way you're how old 32 now and
your house will be paid off when in a
few months
ding
just like that you got this buddy just
like that hold on kelly will pick up
scott she'll get you signed up for a one
year on ramsey plus and put you into
financial peace university make it
happen brother
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
our favorite thing to do on the ramsey
show
is debt-free screams
[Music]
our next favorite thing to do is do debt
free screams in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt
free stage but our mostest of most is
that a word it is now i just made it up
and i own the place our mostest of
mosta's favorite
free scream is our own team members on
the debt-free stage in the lobby
um the only negative is it lowers
productivity in the company because
everybody wants to come out and watch
their friends that they work with
their debt free screen so there's a
bunch of people out here not working
right now
uh watching this debt free stream which
is absolutely awesome because they're
cheering they're cheering their own
along so tyler is with us tyler green is
a paid media specialist with ramsey just
got here been here about 90 days and of
course ashley is with us as well spouse
so way to go guys how much debt did you
pay off i paid off 46 119 and 92 cents
dave love it and how long did that take
you it took us seven months seven months
all right and our rule is we do not ask
the team members their household income
because that's not fair in front of all
their teammates awkward yeah well and
inappropriate and all those kinds of
things so and i'm very inappropriate if
you didn't know so but yeah so but we're
not going to be today so way to go guys
thank you what kind of debt was your 46
000 so it was a little mix of consumer
credit
card debt and we had uh purchased a
vehicle that we needed to pay off um
thankfully we actually cashflowed
college so we didn't do that route but
uh we did buy a lot of things we
shouldn't have bought at that time okay
so you're a new team member for the last
three months right you started this
seven months ago correct tell us the
story how did all this unfold you want
to go ahead and start so
going back to kind of when we our story
starts when we first got married and we
were gifted fpu by a family friend
and we didn't hear know anything about
you my parents did um but we were gifted
fpu and
we were like oh yeah that's cool that's
fun but we didn't do anything with it we
didn't go through the class we didn't
listen course not um we were hoping for
like a couch or yeah like something
usable yeah you know yeah a toaster oven
i mean come on
my parents ended up convincing us to pay
off some debt so we were
we did get out of debt early on in our
marriage
and then we'd have as long as we've been
married six and a half years okay all
right um and then we decided to start
going through the course going through
the program but we did it separately so
part of our dysfunction was he would
listen to the audio tapes in the car and
i would do something at home
but we were never together when we did
it together we went together so we were
in and out of debt for quite a while and
never because you were never one of his
on one of his hot one of his calls yeah
exactly oh wow we weren't on the same
page like we understood the concept we
understood it we were on
not wanting that but not well enough
because we weren't on that same page so
we were in and out of debt for a while
and then fast forward to
shortly after you get pregnant
so we bought the the car and then we had
titus i left who's our oldest i left
teaching i was a teacher
left teaching
stay at home with the kids
and start my own business
and
we we started to realize we needed a few
things in our life one of the things we
needed was a car for her
and we didn't actually have uh
the plan in place we weren't following
our money we weren't paying attention to
the dollars that were going in and
coming out and we just thought we needed
a few things so when she got pregnant
with our second child micah we decided
to go out and buy a car because we
thought that was the smart thing to do
and we realized pretty quickly that we
were
definitely spending more money than we
were bringing in and i remember coming
home one day after looking through the
numbers which was part of the problem is
we didn't communicate much at all
and i actually looked at her and i said
if we don't do something drastic in the
next two weeks we're not gonna have any
money to put uh food on the table or pay
rent and here i i was at that time he
came home i was eight months pregnant oh
yeah that's nice
well played
worst timing in the world yeah
panic a pregnant woman what's wrong man
i was in so at that point i was kind of
in denial because i'm eight months i had
this whole idea
planned up and i was in denial about no
we're going to be fine like we can make
this work we don't need to change things
because we were still not so much on the
same page
and
i said okay well then what
it's like i think we need to sell your
car
and go down to one car and i was
devastated now mind you we had just
bought this car about three months
earlier of course so we we were doing
all the things wrong and
the biggest issue that we had was that
we hadn't communicated up to this point
about about the money thing um we were
making one big decision after the next
and and just getting ourselves further
into the problem um until we had to make
a drastic change uh because we put
ourselves in a drastic situation yeah
and when we decided that we needed to go
ahead and do that um we decided to get
really intense and our story is really
one of intensity because we had been
davish for so long in our lives we
thought we if you can manage the
payments if you can manage the small
things then you're doing okay you're
getting ahead you're making do and
that's not the way to live you're
constantly looking over your shoulder
for a debt collector and i remember we
were shopping around
to try and pay off some of this consumer
debt and i remember one of the credit
card lenders who was potentially going
to help us kind of try and consolidate
or find a way to do that told me if you
don't take my offer then you're going to
not be able to pay off this debt for
like five six seven years you're gonna
be in this for quite a long time and i
told them i think we can find a better
way and that's when we started to dig
into the plan and really find out that
there is a way to do this the right way
and it was on your shelf all along we
dusted it off and decided you know what
we should have done this
for a toaster oven
i know so we sold off that that car and
we decided to make a few other changes
in our life we actually downsized and
got out of our house
moved in with her sister at that time
shortly after micah was born we moved in
with my sister
and cut all of our expenses
by so much
and anything extra that we had so that
extra that we were using for just
surviving we put all of that towards the
debt anything extra that came you went
hardcore scorched earth and did it in
seven months yeah 46 000
like nothing moving with a sister
everything's sold you're not doing
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing yeah so if we were invited
somewhere to a birthday party we hadn't
budgeted in a gift we either went
without a gift or we didn't go and the
thing was dave is we
without a gift and ate free yeah oh yeah
absolutely anytime there was a free food
we were there um but when we started to
look at the numbers i didn't see a way
forward um to being debt-free for at
least three four five years with the
income and the shovel that we had was we
were underwater um the entire time and
what's amazing is when we decided to get
intense
there was supernatural provision that
just showed up and you know we all just
went through this corona season and
there was extra income that was given
around by the government which was
unexpected but we had a plan in place
and we knew where we were going to put
it and we started to attack this thing
and as we did as we got more intense we
found that there was more income coming
into our hands more resources coming
into our hands and we had a choice to
make do we go and spend it on the car or
do we go spend it on nice clothes like
some of my friends used to do or do we
go out and eat for a change because this
is unexpected income or do we put this
towards our debt and really stick to our
guns on this and that's what we did and
that really allowed us to make sure how
does you working here come into this
story so shortly
shortly into this process
we started to really look around and say
we need we need to find something else
to be doing i'm not really liking where
i'm working i wanted something to do
with my life that was meaningful that
was on mission that was passionate and
we had a recruiter that reached out to
us uh from this place right around the
time that we were about to become
debt-free and it was really really
interesting because i thought you had to
be debt-free to work here so i thought
i thought that wasn't i thought i was
going to disqualify myself if i hadn't
had any debt so we through the interview
process were hustling hard to get to the
finish line
because i thought
i thought if we weren't going to you
know if we were going to come to the
last few interviews it was going to be
like so are you debt free or not and i
didn't want to get to that point uh so
that's fun we found money in the couch i
mean i i swear i found sister-in-law's
couch yeah we found it we found it
wherever we could
um but we we uh right before the half
day and getting here we actually made
our last payment oh man wow and i
remember looking at her in the kitchen
and actually telling her hey we're debt
free like we're completely debt free oh
man we don't have to worry about this no
more and i'm so proud of y'all so
welcome aboard thank you there's people
like you guys we won on the team that's
intense and just to put the word out you
don't have to be debt-free to work here
um wow that's intense very cool and you
brought a bunch to cheer you on that's
amazing we did well done tyler and
ashley titus and micah
46 000
paid off with great intensity in seven
months count it down let's hear a
debt-free screen ready guys three two
one
[Applause]
family tree change just like that good
looking family beautiful honor to have
them on our team
rock stars man very cool
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day philippians 2 3
through 4 do nothing out of selfish
ambition or vain conceit
rather in humility value others above
yourselves not looking to your own
interests but each of you to the
interests of others
les brown said in the end it is the
person you become not the things you
achieve
that is the most important
agreed my friend
les brown if you haven't heard him as a
an icon in the uh self-improvement space
from a couple decades back and a
wonderful speaker you can look him up on
youtube and learn a lot about him george
campbell is my co-host today ramsey
personality as we answer your questions
about your life and your money open
phones at
825-5225 reid is in pittsburgh hey reid
what's up
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
uh so i recently uh about a year and a
half ago started working with a friend
of mine back home
and
we're trying to figure out why we can't
we just break even every year we can't
seem to make a profit no matter how much
our sales go up in the business it's
just kind of boggling my mind a little
bit
what's your top line revenues your gross
revenue so
right now when this year we're on track
to do 300 and total sales 300k um when i
started it was like 120 that he did on
average every year and even though the
sales went up we just we're not or
breaking even i don't get it okay so are
you selling an item
uh yeah item in services it's an archery
per shop
it's it's a what
archery pro shop we sell those and
arrows okay all right and so um
what is your uh margin
so we make about 40
on the average of the store um
you should have 120 000 gross profit
then
well we don't pay that much in payroll
is the only thing
stop stop stop stop 300
yeah you said right yeah and you said a
40
gross margin
so that means your gross profit before
expenses should be 120.
after you after you pay for inventory
your cost of goods
that sound right
yeah that does sound right okay and then
what are your expenses other than cost
of goods sold
uh it's basically payroll the building's
been paid off it's been a family
business for 20 some years what's the
power
i mean as right now he the owner took a
couple years without pay uh and i'm the
only one being paid until we get it
built up
um it's like there has to be some
expenses coming out of the 120 if you're
breaking even
so the only thing and he did a bunch of
remodels and stuff but last year we were
so last year we ended at zero this year
after buying all the inventory and we're
looking at all the numbers again
we're back at
breaking
different verse go back to the numbers
120 000. how much are you paid in salary
uh after taxes and everything it's like
35.
yeah but the business has to pay the
taxes out of it and they're paying you
gross what is your salary
oh 25
no
not if you're not after taxes is 35 it's
not 25.
then my math might be wrong on the taxes
so my salary is 25 and from and you take
taxes out of that
so so you're bringing home less than 20
000 a year
yes sir
i thought you said a while ago it was 35
no not the salary so i was the business
has to pay taxes on
whatever it pays me as well because i
was rounding up for that
okay so the cost to the business of you
is thirty thousand
thirty five thousand okay yeah so that
puts us at what uh one we said 140 so
that puts us at 105. where are you guys
spending that 105 000.
he did a bunch of remodels last year we
that was even at the end of the year so
you spent 105 000 on remodels
no that was like i said it was paid off
last year the only thing i could think
of we've done something i now know why
you're broke
because you have no freaking idea what's
going on inside this business
okay i've asked you six ways from sunday
where this money's going and you can't
seem to answer it you're going in
circles chasing your tail okay so you
guys need to sit down and explain to
yourselves
where your hundred and forty thousand
dollars gross profit is going
some of it is going to read
some of it is going to the remodel but
you have to put actual freaking numbers
on that and that 140 should be
after all inventory restock is paid
unless you're ordering excess inventory
more than you sold
because the other hundred and uh sixty
thousand the sixty percent cost of goods
sold giving you a forty percent gross
margin should give you inventory restock
unless you're over stocking so it sounds
to me like you're stocking and over
remodeling
and taking no and the owner's taking no
money out of the business
it's what it sounds like but you guys
need to know where your money is going
you're just spending it until it's gone
and then wondering what happened
and so doing a budget is looking out the
windshield yeah we just did a budgeting
for business episode on entre leadership
dave and we talked about how your profit
and loss statement is not a budget
that's just telling you what happened
but i think you need to start there reid
look at the profit and loss statement
start doing a budget with your friends
you guys need to be looking these
numbers every week and start really
digging into this thing because there's
a lot more questions here than answers
yeah you got to get you got to treat
this like it's a crisis because it is
you're not making any money and he's not
making any money and you got three
hundred thousand dollars coming in the
front door and it's all going back out
the back door you're not making hardly
any money and he's not making any
because he's spending it all on excess
inventory and remodeling it sounds like
but you don't know the numbers
and so the first step to making money is
to do it on purpose
and profit does not just occur you
cannot sell enough to out earn your
stupidity
you have to i've tried it i tried it for
years because i'm a good salesman i can
i know how to make money but you have to
have a game plan and go okay
this is what we're going to spend and
we're not going to do any more
remodeling until we take a profit out
well you know we got enough i mean the
store we have made 300k we don't need to
upgrade that until we have extra money
and when the owner makes zero there is
no extra money
so owner takes money out
all the team members including you take
money out
and uh after you're running a solid
business plan called a budget
and that's you're going to budget this
is what we're going to make and this is
where it's going to go and it's not
going anywhere other than where we tell
it to
but you're getting to the end of the
year and wondering what happened instead
of telling your money what to do up
front that's your problem that's how
you're not profitable tom's in portland
maine hey tom how are you
hey dude i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
my wife and i are currently on baby
steps four five and six we have three
children and are quickly outgrowing our
smaller home we're looking for an
upgrade for the quote unquote dream home
but as you know the real estate market
is very hot at the moment
we have a rental property that brings in
roughly 20k a year in profit and have
about 300k in equity on that rental so
my question to you is should we sell the
rental
take the capital and use it to purchase
that dream home where it should get us
into a 15-year 25 of our take-home pay
or keep the rental and the cash flow and
enter into a 30-year mortgage and attack
the mortgage with the extra cash flow
over time
if i woke up in your shoes as much as i
love rental real estate i would still
sell it
and i might give you a third option i
might sell the rental while the market's
hot
and then wait a little bit
and let's sit on that cash
and let's let this market chill out a
little bit
and then let that 300 work a little
harder for you when you get ready to buy
um of course that also means when you
sell your current home it's not going to
sell as high but so what you're what
you're doing is you're maxing out the
price on the rental you're not maxing
out the price on your purchase and
you're not maxing out the price on your
personal now real estate may go on up a
little bit while you wait but it'll calm
down and the selection in the inventory
on your upgrade um
is there and i would suggest you change
your language i would not use the word
dream home and i would not use the words
forever home because no home is either
you're never there forever
it always changes and you're not and
it's not a dream home because your
dreams change
about the time you move in yeah
that's how it works so
just get you a nicer home it's an
upgrade home that's the only language
you need and you've earned that and
that's that's okay that's how i would do
it good job george thank you it's been
fun george campbell ramsey personality
my co-host today ben and kelly in the
booth i'm dave ramsey your host we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show
did you know the ramsay show is one of
the most popular podcasts in the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
you